deux bons soirs je commence avec vous
madame borgès da silva pourquoi fermer
l'économie à 40% si par exemple on était
comme au niveau du printemps et dernier
pourquoi ce serait la chose à faire
selon vous mais en fait ce qu'il faut
savoir si con et 80 experts professeur
d'université en santé sans sciences
sociales et économiques dans cette
lettre qui sonne inquiet par la
croissance des cartes
donc on est accueilli par la croissance
dans le cas des cas et l'impact qu'elle
peut avoir à la fois sur une baie le
nombre de cas le nombre de décès mais
aussi sur les hospitalisations et est en
fait aussi sur les ressources humaines
au travers de la santé qui sont déjà à
bout de souffle qui ne seront pas en
mesure de prendre une surcharge des
hospitalisations ou deux cas
supplémentaires
ok et est-ce qu'on peut être on comprend
très bien les avantages sur le plan de
la santé publique vous venez très très
bien de le dire mais l'argument
économique mais chez michou en faveur
d'un confinement pendant la période des
fêtes
quel est il alors si on écoute nos
collègues la santé publique qui nous
disent qu'on s'en va et avis il est
inévitablement vers une situation qui va
être difficile de contrôler le virus est
bien en ce moment et donc on va voir un
confinement
la question c'est de savoir quand il va
se dérouler et donc c'est clair qu'il va
avoir des impacts négatifs et je pense
c'est les informations qu'elle faisait
référence tout à l'heure la direction de
fci site c'est tout à fait clair il va
avoir des impacts négatifs dans la
question c'est dire quand est ce qu'on
fait et nous ce qu'on dit c'est pendant
la période des fêtes les impacts
économiques sont un peu moindre que si
on attend
et deuxièmement si on regarde la
situation ce qu'on a fait au printemps
le québec était une des premières j'ai
deux juridictions au canada à agir et
l'emploi bien sûr a souffert à court
terme mais à long terme on a connu une
récupération d'un poids qui était
beaucoup plus rapide qu'ailleurs aux
cadres ont parfois ne pas appliquer la
même idée ici mais est ce que j'entends
de vous c'est quand est-ce qu'on le fait
et non pas si on le fait
madame borgia silva il ya dans votre
esprit il sera un moment donné
obligatoire de faire un nouveau
confinement mai
en l'état des choses on le remarque les
cas continuent de suivre une tendance
croissante
donc on a une baisse de la dépense aux
recommandations de santé publique peut
être certainement mais on arrive à aux
limites en fait des mesures qui sont
actuellement en place
donc on a cette inquiétude de la
croissance des cas mais comme je le
disais précédemment et donc le moyen
après qui reste c'est le la mise sur
pause du québec comme l'a fait la france
la nouvelle zélande l'australie et
l'allemagne qui vient d'annoncer aussi
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il risque sur le
plan de la santé publique de créer
d'autres problèmes en confinant la
société mais là encore c'est sûr que les
problèmes de santé mentale nous guette
mais vaut-il mieux confinés pendant un
moment où on est tous en poste du moins
la plupart des gens sont en congé et
savent que pendant ces deux semaines là
ils vont être en congé et prendre une
pause plutôt que de confignon en plein
milieu de mois de janvier ou non
seulement on va mettre à mal l'économie
mais c'est surtout que quand on met à
mal konami c'est le chômage la pauvreté
la vulnérabilité et la santé mentale qui
en prennent un gros coup donc c'est pour
cette raison-là que les experts en santé
publique se sont ralliés à cette lettre
et propose en fait de profiter du congé
des fêtes pour mettre le québec sur
points monsieur michaud quand la fci dit
je sais pas si il exagère mais il
affirme qu'un deuxième confinement en
porterait la moitié des pme du québec
est ce qu'un deuxième confinement ne
serait pas trop cher payé pour
l'ensemble du québec
il ya deux informations qui demandent
tout ça d'abord qu'est-ce qu'on ferait
au niveau du soutien des entreprises
donc dans un cas comme celui-là est
encore une fois si on se dirige vers ça
c'est clair qui va avoir des impacts
négatifs pour les entreprises maintenant
dans la mer situation idéale tout le
monde suit les mesures mises en place
ont réussi à contrôler l'évolution des
cas et on n'a pas besoin d'aucune dessus
de ces mesures
aujourd'hui ce qu'on dit c'est que ça
sente difficile donc d'entrevoir une
possibilité comme ça il va falloir
resserrer les mesures et d'un point de
vue économique c'est clair qu'il va
falloir réfléchir à une solution
confinement avec potentiellement
compensation s'il faut le faire
cela dit le collectif très important de
mentionner n'a pas voulu s'avancer sur
les moyens de compenser sur la façon de
faire un nom on peut voulu établir donc
le principe que l'économie la santé
savoir père n'y a pas d'opposition faut
d'abord contrôler la pandémie et puis
après on en viendra potentiellement
pouvoir reprendre jusqu'à quel point
dans ces deux semaines là où l'activité
déjà pas mal arrêté pour bien déjà
jusqu'à quel point un confinement serait
très utile alors qu'il pourra avoir
madame de borja da silva des effets
économiques bien important pour les
entreprises qui sera obligé de fermer
alors qu'elles sont généralement
ouvertes même si l'activité différence
durant ces deux semaines là mais ce
qu'on voit en fait dans les éclosions
c'est que les éclosions milieu dans
l'est en fait on voit qu'il ya beaucoup
d'éclosion mieux travail qui suivent une
tendance croissante également et ce
qu'on voit c'est que ces éclosions de
travail se retrouve particulièrement
dans le commerce de détail et le
commerce de gros
donc ce sont des milieux travail qu'il
faut oser fermer si on veut circonscrire
ces éclosions et réduire la propagation
de la cofidis mme il ya des experts en
santé publique qui dit c'est pas 14 que
ça prend c'est 28 jours vous en pensez
quoi
ils ont raison les données probantes et
épidémies utiliser les logiquement à
blanc ces quatre semaines que ça
prendrait au minimum
mais dans le contexte en ralliant 80
experts on s'est entendu sur deux
semaines dans la mesure où nos enfants
sont jean en congé et c'est important
pour les enfants
à l'école l'éducation étant à la base de
toute société donc on s'est entendu sur
ces domaines là pendant le congé
scolaire
mais personnellement en tant qu'ex en
santé publique je suis d'accord que ce
serait quelques semaines qu'ils
apprendraient pourrait avoir un impact
réel en fait ces deux semaines la
longueur en mètres d'avoir un de mettre
un frein disons à la co lead et on
proposait à la propagation mais ne
trompe pas la neutraliser complètement
pierre carles michaud le ministre de la
santé christian dubé a semblé indiquer
aujourd'hui en point de presse qu'ils
avaient assez de règles en place
actuellement
quelles seraient les conséquences selon
vous de ne pas appliquer finalement la
proposition vous faites aujourd'hui il
faut voir si les gens se mettent à
suivre comme par magie les règles sont
déjà mises en place et peut-être qu'on
peut espérer qu'à se permet d'en douter
le tout petit peu mais c'est ça et on a
l'impression qu'il ya une part de la
population qui ne respecte pas des
règles de toute façon donc on se demande
jusqu'à quel point un confinement serait
aurait eu un effet réel sur la deuxième
vague
il est peut-être le côté c c'est une
règle qui est beaucoup plus 5 par faut
comprendre que dans les dernières
semaines c'est à en perdre son latin
alors en termes de coût et l'excité de
savoir où on peut aller
et pendant les fêtes la est-ce qu'on
peut aller en seconde jambe pour fait
avec la famille ou non et 1 ci dessus
donc il ya peut-être un fn ps comptait
qu'un confinement ça donne une pause à
tout le monde une pose aussi pour les
travailleurs de devoir mettre un masque
au travail de devoir suivre les mesures
donc on peut aussi voir comme une pause
il ya des soufflement et puis se donner
une chance pour divers ok on faire est
là dessus merci pour vos explications
votre travail roxane borgès da silva et
pierre carde michaud merci